We continue to
follow breaking news for you
this morning.
Just frightening scenes
coming out of Japan
on this New Year's Day.
Japan's West Coast
reeling after a powerful 7.5 magnitude
quake caused
widespread damage,
triggered tsunami warnings
and four foot tsunami waves.
This is the moment that the quake struck
just a few hours ago.
You see that building
crumbling to the ground
On the screens, upper left side there.
And take a look at the scene
from inside of an office building
in
That's the first time
I'm seeing this video.
You can see
just how long it goes on
and just how violent that shaking is.
Houses have collapsed.
We have seen pictures of roofs there
just fallen down.
The earthquake
also caused fires in some areas.
And at this moment,
tsunami warnings do remain in effect.
They have been downgraded.
You can see
the initial impact
of one of these tsunamis,
one of these small waves there.
It doesn't look like much,
but this can be a threat,
particularly if you get repeated waves.
The warnings
now are of waves of up to ten feet
We have full team coverage for you.
CNN's Kanako
Montgomery is in Tokyo,
Derek Van Dam at the weather center.
And I go first to you.
What are you hearing at this point
from the Japanese government
Yeah, John.
So right now it's currently
nighttime in Japan,
so we're still waiting to confirm
a lot of outstanding questions
about the extent of the devastation
from the earthquake
and subsequent tsunami.
But what we do know
is that
33,000 homes in Ishikawa Prefecture,
which is very close to the epicenter,
have lost power.
We also know that bullet
train lines have been suspended.
Some roads have had cracks in them,
making it very difficult
for emergency
medical personnel to get to survivors.
We also know that fires
have broken out across
Ishikawa Prefecture
and a thousand self-defense
force personnel have been dispatched
to aid in evacuation efforts.
This is along with 1700 firefighters
also to help in evacuation efforts.
Now, 20
self-defense force
aircrafts are also monitoring the area
to just
try to get a sense
of the extent of this devastation.
Now, also,
I just want to point out
that this did happen on New Year's Day,
a time
when many people
are celebrating New Year's
with their families in their homes,
with their loved ones.
And when this quake hit at 4:10 p.m.,
that initial quake hit at 4:10 p.m.,
it shocked the entire country.
People were forced to leave their homes,
leave their belongings
and evacuate to higher ground.
Of course,
the aftershocks
that followed soon
afterwards were also very powerful.
And it's
reminding a lot of people of the 2011
Tohoku earthquake and tsunami
because of just how long the quakes are.
How the tsunami warnings
have also been issued, John.
And just really a lot of fear
and just
lots to confirm
about the extent of devastation
really early days into sort of
assessing the damage. Hanako, thank you.
Let me bring Derek into the conversation.
Derek as we just said,
we know the tsunami warnings
have been downgraded.
But help us understand
practically what that means.
I mean, what is the risk right now?
Well, John, what you're seeing
is some really stunning
new video
coming out of the Ishikawa Prefecture.
This this is new to us.
And you're looking at Suzhou City, Japan.
So this is on the opposite
side of the peninsula
and just zooming in.
What you're looking at is a brick wall.
Some of the seawall here, we're
analyzing this video on the fly.
So it's a bit tricky to establish
exactly what's going on.
But we believe that
this is the moment
the tsunami,
the initial tsunami wave impacted
this part of the Ishikawa Prefecture.
And you can see the water
kind of pummeling over that seawall,
which we would have to
guess here
is several meters high
if it's protecting the harbor.
But you can see the waves
splashing up into the populated areas.
I'm going to reset my graphics here
and just give a little bit
more of an indication of
where exactly this is.
We've zoomed in to Suzhou City
and there is that breakwater wall.
This is the population area.
And again,
this is on the opposite side
of where
the magnitude 7.5
earthquake actually occurred.
So we're getting
some profound video of the tsunami wave
that has actually moved in
and you could see
other areas there
fitting that narrative of waves over
four feet
in some instances, with tsunami warnings
still ongoing across those Western
Asian shorelines
of the country of Japan,
particularly across the Honshu region.
All right.
Derek Van Dam, thanks to you.
Hanako Montgomery who is in Tokyo.
Our thanks to both of you.
Let's continue the conversation now.
Joining us now is Robert Geller.
He is a seismologist
and emeritus
professor at the University of Tokyo.
Robert good to have you today.
Can I just ask I mean, you are in Tokyo.
Did you feel the earthquake?
Can you share with us
what your experience was?
Well, I felt the earthquake,
but only very, very low level shaking.
I had the TV on and on.
No warnings of an imminent earthquake
striking a prefecture.
Where would repeat in on a loop
over and over again with the kind of horn
warning people.
So not
that was very dramatic,
but actually,
you could hardly feel anything in Tokyo.
Well, that's
really interesting in the video
that we're showing.
I'm not sure
if you can see the screen right now,
but the video is also quite
dramatic monitors
and office buildings really shaking
from from their perspective.
What is the biggest risk right now?
What are you watching right now?
Well, there are tourists slow.
One is the buildings
that have collapsed
or partially collapsed.
If there are people trapped in them,
all the emergency forces
have about 48 hours to get the people out
or mostly it's too late.
So so that's a race against time.
And I'm sure
the firemen and self-defense forces
will do the best they can.
The second risk
is there's a very small problem
it may be only one or 2%
that you could have
an even bigger earthquake
in the next week or two.
There sure to be aftershocks,
but almost all the time
they're smaller than the main shock.
So the aftershocks will only be
a problem
for buildings
that have already been damaged
and then any little further block in
the march them.
But if you have a bigger earthquake
that could really be a problem
is not very likely,
but it's not impossible right now.
Non-zero percent chance
we're talking about here.
Some people do need to be on alert.
We have seen some images
of some of the smaller waves.
The initial tsunamis that did did occur
from this.
There are still warnings in effect
for waves of up to ten feet high.
How long do you think
people need to be on alert
for the water there?
Well, the
flow from the main shock
probably not that much longer.
I think
perhaps the government
is being a little overly cautious
bearing in mind what happened in 2011
when you know
it's one of these better safe
than sorry things
if people
stay away from their homes for 24 hours
that's probably not such a bad
thing.
Just in case.
Extra precautions certainly in order
given what happened in 2011
and the severity of this quake.
It was a very powerful earthquake.
Still assessing the damage from Professor
Robert Keller
we do appreciate you being with us.
Thank you so much. Happy New Year to you.